what fan of The Legend of Zelda hasn't
heard of the timeline and therefore what
fan of The Legend of Zelda doesn't know
that the timeline has its mysteries it
starts out pretty straightforward
there's an unbreakable curse cast upon
the descendants of hialeah and the
spirit of the hero who will forever
defend the golden Triforce and they do
battle over and over across an
ever-growing amount of time
things only really start to get complex
when the game ocarina of time splits the
timeline which is still pretty
understandable when you try to explain
it I mean Linc beats Ganondorf and then
reverts back in time to before any of
the events even occurred resulting in
Ganondorf being banished to the Twilight
Realm two separate endings for two
separate timelines split within one game
revolving around one individual it makes
sense but unfortunately things stop
making perfect sense there the third
timeline split is the wrench in the
system you see it isn't split like the
adult and child timelines were this one
was split because of a literal what if
statement the Fallen timeline only
happens if link is defeated but wait
isn't he victorious in the other two
timelines you know the ones you actually
play through I mean those other
timelines couldn't even exist if he
hadn't beaten Ganondorf yep that's also
true but the Fallen timeline is just as
canon as the other two
meaning link winning and Link die are
both actual events that have to occur as
per the Canon storyline well the only
way that's possible is if there are not
only multiple timelines but also
multiple realities that spawn based on
choices made by the characters in said
realities for a rough example imagine if
in their ending bat Ganon swings to the
left and Link chooses to dodge to the
right well he would survive but if Ganon
swung to the left again in link also
accidentally dodged in the same
direction you get hit and die according
to the multiverse theory these two
possibilities are both their own
realities just as real as each other and
the Zelda timeline really seems to him
that this is what they're going for with
the Fallen timeline I mean there are
literally entire timelines and games
that couldn't even take place at all if
hero of time linked
didn't both live and die could this
Zelda multiverse theory explain other
strange realms we've taken a peek at
across the games like Laurel termina the
Sacred Realm or even breath of the wild
itself which seems to be both connected
and disconnected from all previous
timelines but that's just a theory
mini theory at that let me know what you
guys think in the comments below
hey thanks so much for watching guys I
wanted to get a video out before this
crazy week really starts because I'm not
sure if I'll be able to at all this
weekend you know how it is egg nog stuff
like that anyway I hope you enjoyed the
first of these little mini theories I'll
be doing here and there as always huge
thanks to my faithful patrons follow me
on Twitter and Instagram and join my
discord and all that good stuff via
links in the description below
this is Mastana bandits signing out have
a great rest of your day and hey Merry
Christmas or whatever you're celebrating
peace
[Music]